dans le cadre du concours du plus beau
collège fleury lancé par le conseil
départemental les collèges volontaires
sont invités à repenser l'aménagement
d'un ou plusieurs espaces de leur choix
le collège simon lucas l'étang salé a
pris le parti d'embellir sa cour bas ont
déjà en a baptisé cet espace le bon coin
ça veut dire l'espace botanique naturel
ou couleur de l'océan indien le blason
voilà lamont la montagne représente
s'est représentée par les rochers on a
le bateau il ya les 3èmes aussi les
3èmes en fait ça signifie 3000 en
chiffres romains ce qui était à l'époque
estimé par balles et les les anciens et
il avait estimé qu'ils et 3000 mètres
d'altitude et c'était pas vraiment trop
trompé vu qu'il ya que 70 mètres de
différence
après il ya le le bateau le saint-alexis
qui a découvert la réunion il est
représenté ici bas paroles et paroles
fin ça représente le quai il vient
contempler le jardin botanique
pour le proviseur du collège il est très
important que les élèves contribuer à
l'embellissement de leur établissement
ce projet permet aux jeunes de découvrir
les métiers liés à l'urbanisme à
l'architecturé à l'environnement
l'amélioration du cadre de vie des
élèves a un impact sur la baisse des
incivilités mais aussi sur
l'apprentissage
alors pour qu'ils s'approprient leur
espace assez leur collège c'est vrai
aussi pour mes collègues enseignants
c'est vrai aussi pour mes collègues att
eux c'est ils doivent s'approprier leur
leur établissement et s'il embellissent
leurs espaces ils n'ont pas jeté de
papier c'est eux
en gros ça nous un travail de plusieurs
mois qui a nécessité de nombreuses
compétences afin d'obtenir le résultat
désiré les agents du conseil
départemental ont participé à ce projet
en aidant les élèves à mettre en place
leur espace et en leur transmettant leur
savoir
on a été convié à un projet dans le
cadre du concours de collage fleury est
ce projet a pour le mérite d'avoir réuni
tout le monde autour de ce cette
entreprise là les agents les professeurs
les élèves et on a on a pu découvrir des
talents à savoir faire mais surtout une
cohésion sociale extraordinaire on
n'attend plus que les délibérations du
jury pour savoir quel collège remportera
la palme du plus beau collège fleury